mais chers collègues nous recevons
maintenant Monsieur Charles d'Anjou
président du média omerta qui en
visioconférence et Monsieur Régis le
sommier rédacteur en chef de ce même
média omerta messieurs je vous remercie
d'avoir répondu à notre convocation dans
un délai serrés et vous êtes rendus
disponible pour répondre à nos questions
comme vous le savez notre commission
d'enquête parlementaire travaille depuis
plusieurs mois sur les ingérences les
menaces les réalités de ces ingérences
de plusieurs puissances étrangères dans
la vie politique économique et auprès
des relais d'opinion de notre pays
naturellement les travaux de la
commission suite à l'audition tendance à
l'ombre d'experts d'agences de
renseignements et d'institution
française se sont concentrés sur un
certain nombre de zones géographiques
particulièrement hostiles ou soupçonné
d'entretenir des tentatives ou des
réalités d'ingérence en particulier
l'espace anciennement soviétique et le
régime de Vladimir Poutine à ce titre
nous nous sommes intéressés notamment
aux ingérences étrangères potentiel ou
avéré dans la précédente les réseaux
sociaux et dans une manière générale
dans la façon dont nos concitoyens sont
informés mais aussi dans d'autres médias
occidentaux et en particulier français
pour être influencé le média omerta que
vous diriez et de création récente il
est diffusé principalement en ligne mais
il publie également un magazine papier
d'ailleurs il y a aussi de la publicité
en tout cas sur les kiosques parisiens
que j'ai pu observer du fait de son
titre et d'une ligne éditoriale jugée
par certains mais vous pourrez
évidemment y répondre très proche des
positions du régime russe ou en faveur
d'un certain nombre d'actions assimilé à
celle du régime russe il suscite des
interrogations sur lesquels nous
souhaiterions recueillir vos
explications et votre témoignage je
tiens à préciser en tant que président
de la commission que nous notionnons pas
les gens au hasard ou selon les rumeurs
du tout Paris les motivations de nos
auditions sont toujours fondées sur les
informations que nous ont été transmises
par d'autres auditions ou par des
documents
sérieux que nous avons pu consulter
cette audition je le précise et public
elle est plus elle est retransmise en
direct sur le site de l'Assemblée
nationale l'enregistrement vidéo sera
ensuite disponible à la demande elle est
ouverte à la presse
monsieur le sommier puis Monsieur
Charles d'Anjou je vous laisserai la
parole pour une intervention auliminaire
d'une dizaine de minutes chacun si
possible à respecter ce temps même si
c'est pas toujours facile nous
poursuivrons ensuite nos échanges des
questions de votre serviteur de madame
la rapporteur et des commissaires
présents je vous rappelle qu'au titre de
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires les
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête doivent prêter le
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité aussi je vous
invite monsieur le sommier à lever la
main droite et à dire je le jure
je vous remercie Monsieur Charles
d'Anjou je vous invite à lever la main
droite et à dire je le jure
je mesure
je vous remercie vous avez la parole je
vous propose de commencer par Monsieur
le sommier
vous m'entendez bien là voilà oui donc
comme vous l'avez signifié j'ai je vais
je suis donc directeur de la rédaction
d'omerta le média omerta a été lancé en
novembre dernier il a donc 6 mois
d'existence et on a fourni un certain
nombre de contenu et notamment
prioritairement des documentaires
puisque c'est l'un des premiers
objectifs vous avez mentionné également
la création d'un tri trimestriel
puisqu'on ça va être sa périodicité donc
d'amagisme qui qui vient accompagner ce
média et qui vient lui donner une forme
voilà une forme papier
pour ce qui est de
l'historique puisque
si je suis là c'est pour pour expliquer
ce qui me motive chez omerta je vais
parler un petit peu de mon passé j'ai
été donc j'ai 54 ans je suis journaliste
grand reporter depuis une vingtaine
d'années
j'ai été j'ai travaillé pour pour Paris
Match pendant 27 ans
jusqu'en juin 2020
et j'ai couvert pour Paris Match un
certain nombre de conflits
notamment
l'Irak l'Afghanistan la Syrie le Sahel
de façon assez importante avec l'armée
française mais aussi j'ai été
correspondant de la rédaction de Paris
Match aux États-Unis pendant 6 ans
États-Unis OK dans lequel j'ai
aujourd'hui deux enfants qui vivent à
Los Angeles voilà c'est les États-Unis
d'ailleurs qui m'ont amené à
comment prendre une orientation de
reporter de guerre puisque c'est en
couvrant l'Irak avec les troupes
américaines que j'ai fait mes premières
armes comme reporter de guerre
dans les années 2000 voilà depuis j'ai
suivi absolument tous les conflits et
j'ai ma collaboration avec Paris Match
c'est puisque j'en ai été licencié pour
des raisons qui que je ne vais pas
détailler ici mais qui n'ont rien à voir
avec mes compétences professionnelles en
juin 2020 après j'ai réalisé deux
documentaires sur l'Afghanistan au
moment de la chute de Kaboul et du
retour d'état Liban pour pour le média
Canal+ et j'ai rejoint la rédaction
d'art et France dans laquelle j'ai passé
6 mois avant la fermeture de cette
chaîne donc là j'ai une période
d'environ trois mois au chômage et je
suis ensuite
j'ai rejoint la rédaction d'omerta on a
décidé donc de créer ce média qui est
innove dans le sens où il présente un
média purement digital et c'était une
pour moi une idée que j'avais déjà eu
quand j'étais à Paris Match c'est-à-dire
décliner
moi étant un homme du texte et de et de
l'image fixe
sur des nouveaux supports c'est ce que
j'avais fait avant et donc omerta me
permettait justement de de comment
de façon vraiment vraiment intéressante
avec une ligne éditoriale précise cette
ligne éditoriale étant quand on parle de
quelque chose on parle du terrain c'est
à dire on ne fait pas de la spéculation
comme on peut en voir qui a son intérêt
aussi sur des chaînes d'infos en continu
mais on va sur le terrain et on rapporte
les faits c'est moi personnellement ce
qu'on m'a toujours appris dans le
journaliste c'est la priorité au terrain
la priorité à ceux qui vont sur place
qui regardent qui observent qui qui
tente des micros et qui essaient de
travailler souvent ce que c'est un
métier de grand reporter il faut le
préciser qui est extrêmement dangereux
qui a un coût aussi humain assez
important et psychologique voilà donc
voilà un petit peu pour résumer qu'ils
ont été
mes motivations pour être à omerta
depuis que je suis omerta géralisé un
certain nombre de reportages sur le
front en Ukraine sur le Kosovo et le
dernier puisque je reviens d'avoir passé
15 jours en Afghanistan mon dernier
reportage sur l'Afghanistan sera
disponible à partir de vendredi sur la
plateforme Bertha évidemment
je vous remercie monsieur d'Anjou
oui merci monsieur le Président alors je
m'appelle Charles d'Anjou j'ai 41 ans je
suis papa de deux enfants
je suis
un entrepreneur j'ai commencé à mon
premier séjour en Russie date de mon
stage de fin d'étude de Master 2 je
politique la Sorbonne c'est un pays que
je connais bien et que dans lequel j'ai
habité plusieurs années
jusqu'en 2014 où je suis rentré en
France pendant trois ans
j'ai une comment dire une activité un
engagement politique au sein du parti
fin de l'UMP puis des républicains
j'étais candidat législativement 2017 et
en 2018 j'ai décidé de reprendre une vie
professionnelle active et de
redévelopper de développer mes affaires
qui ont toujours été à l'international
dans les pays de l'Est en particulier
donc en Russie en Ukraine au Kazakhstan
en Roumanie mais pas uniquement puisque
j'ai travaillé
j'ai travaillé aussi un peu en Afrique
notamment en Libye et donc en 2018 je
pars me réinstaller à Moscou et je
redéveloppe mes activités
professionnelles qui sont
c'est pas un secret parce que c'est
mentionné par la presse notamment dans
la sécurité dans la sûreté
essentiellement pour des pour des
groupes français allemands ou italiens
présents en Russie en Ukraine Kazakhstan
ça c'est ça a toujours été l'essentiel
de ma clientèle jamais eu jamais eu de
clients russes qui soient que ce soit
une société privée ou évidemment le
évidemment les Targus et puis
[Musique]
et puis en
janvier 2022
c'est pas non plus un secret je suis ami
avec grand reporter de guerre de TF1 qui
s'appelle ils ont boudoul
nous sommes vus à Paris elle cherchait
des idées de sujets en Russie et il y
avait à l'époque plusieurs sujets
intéressants il y avait par exemple
Yamal avec le
le pipeline en stream 2 qui pourrait
être intéressant de couvrir depuis les
champs d'extraction dans le grand
nord-us jusqu'au jusqu'au pipeline en
lui-même qui arrive en Allemagne mais il
y avait aussi le conflit à l'époque gelé
du don de basse on est là vraiment
mi-janvier donc
la guerre n'a pas encore n'a pas encore
démarré et avec l'accord de sa rédaction
sur un acteur en chef elle a
et là souhaité réaliser une série de
reportages d'une dizaine de jours je
l'ai aidé
comment dire à organiser le voyage
quand on va dans le don de basse à
l'époque il faut faire des demandes
d'actualité qui se trouve sur le site
internet de la de la république
autoproclamée de dièse ou de celle de
lougance donc j'ai fait les demandes
d'accréditation on a reçu les demandes
les marchés de confirmations qu'on était
accrédité et donc je l'accompagnais
comme chauffeur traducteur le à partir
du 5 février date à laquelle nous sommes
entrés dans le don de basse et avec elle
je l'ai suivi évidemment un jris un
cameraman on a réalisé une
dix jours de reportage jusqu'au jusqu'au
24 février ou à 5h du matin
nous sommes réveillés par un téléphone
de la de la rédaction qui annonce que
Vladimir Poutine déclenché
la guerre et donc là on
les liserons et le cameraman campagne
que ils vont rester plusieurs semaines
voire plusieurs mois sur place parce
qu'il est très difficile d'organiser une
relève dans des dans de bonnes
conditions et dans des comment dire dans
un apte de temps court et donc j'accepte
de rester de rester avec eux des
accompagner et au total on passe près de
trois mois dans le monde basse en
en suivant les opérations de l'armée
russe puisqu'on est côté on est côté
prorus et puis l'armée russe entre en
suivant le long de masse donc on suit
les deux entités
jusqu'à la bataille de Mario Paul qui
est un peu le point culminant de tout ce
qu'on a fait je pense qu'on totalité on
doit réaliser une trentaine de
reportages des sujets pour le 20H
essentiellement pour le 20h de TF1
je précise que donc moi j'accompagne en
tant que chauffeur et et quand il y a
besoin interprète
la partie montage du reportage est
effectué par par la journaliste et par
le cameraman
et sur c'est à peu près 30 reportages il
y a pas un seul reportage qui a été
coupé à Paris qui a fait l'objet d'une
critique
qui a été remis en cause etc c'était
vraiment donné la parole
je dirais au fait et uniquement au fait
voilà
je quitte ensuite le don de base puisque
ça faisait déjà trois mois donc c'était
j'avais eu mon activité professionnelle
un peu entre parenthèses ma vie
familiale aussi et donc je rentre à
Moscou et
en étant dans le basse en fait chaque
jour on était quasiment sur le sur le
terrain et on avait souvent 4 à 5 heures
de
rush c'est à dire de vidéos en fait
d'enregistrement pour des sujets qui
faisaient en général entre 3 et 4
minutes et donc je voyais bien que il y
avait beaucoup de beaucoup de ce qu'on
avait filmé
ne pouvait pas être conservé pour le
pour le pour le reportage et à jamais
l'idée de en fait de
pouvoir utiliser ce genre de de
matériaux intéressants pour en faire des
formes à longs à destination d'un public
qui en est un public français qui en
fait adore regarder Netflix parce que il
trouve des attentes de reportages de
films d'action etc mais
l'intérêt de ce genre de théâtre
d'opérations il y en a il y en a
beaucoup d'autres dans le monde c'est
que en fait en filmant en ayant une
comment dire en ayant des des vidéos
intéressantes en fait vous pouvez
vous faites pas du Netflix enfin vous
faites du Netflix mais avec la vie
réelle avec ce qui se passe réellement
et j'ai compris enfin je
j'étais persuadé que ça pourrait
intéresser
auditoire en France et donc j'ai
commencé à travailler sur le projet
et j'ai contacté Régis le sommier que
j'avais vu je pense une fois en 2018 si
je ne me trompe pas et c'était au mois
de juillet et je lui ai demandé puisque
pour réaliser un projet comme ça pas
seulement une question de financement
sans on va en parler mais il faut
surtout que le média soit incarné par un
journaliste professionnel un journaliste
professionnel qui qui sache s'organiser
tenir une rédaction développer un média
mais qui est aussi l'expérience du
terrain parce qu'en fait
des
profils comme Régis il y en a je dirais
il y en a très peu sur le marché
c'est-à-dire que Régis à son actif
comme liseron d'ailleurs ils ont un
certain nombre de théâtre d'opérations
compliqués avec des ils ont remporté des
prix etc
Régis connaît bien connaît bien tout ça
et donc si Régis avait au mois de
juillet dit refuser de d'entrer dans
l'aventure je pense que j'aurais au
minimum du différé le la réalisation du
projet pour trouver un profil un autre
profil rare dans son genre heureusement
pour moi il a accepté et donc j'ai monté
le projet c'est à dire monter les
sociétés au mois de au mois d'août donc
dans un laps de temps très court
et nous avons commencé à travailler dès
le 1er septembre avec un lancement le 16
novembre avec trois trois documentaires
un que j'ai réalisé avec Régis
ce que je l'accompagnais en
Ukraine mes côtés côté russe au mois de
septembre donc un qui s'appelait front
russe le deuxième sur l'Arménie qui a
été réalisé par
oui c'est ça
de la société
dans l'attente de la reconnaissance de
reconnexion
est-ce que ça remarque monsieur le
monsieur d'Anjou vous entendez
écoutez clémente au service de regarder
s'il est possible de relancer la
connexion et dans la tente je vous
propose au commissaire que nous posions
nos questions à Monsieur le sommier
nous allons procéder nous allons
procéder ainsi à Monsieur d'Anjou vous
êtes trop connecté
est-ce que les services pour m'informer
c'est la connexion fonctionne s'il vous
plaît dans l'attente nous allons passer
aux questions est-ce que Monsieur est-ce
que nigox puisque je vous dis
ça y est je suis revenu
juste si vous le permettez monsieur le
Président pour terminer pour faire très
court ce que je disais c'est que ce
n'est pas un projet caritatif
c'est-à-dire que pour moi c'est comme
les entreprises que je dis depuis monter
c'est un projet qui doit à l'horizon
d'un an être pérenne sur le plan
financier nous le recevons aucune
subvention
absolument aucune subvention c'est à
dire que tous les fonds qui ont été
injectés sont des fonds propres et que
ce média n'est pas un c'est pas une
chaîne Youtube on a une chaîne Youtube
mais c'est pas le modèle financier n'est
pas une chaîne Youtube le modèle c'est
un abonnement à quelques 99 par mois et
donc un contenu exclusif qui est réservé
à des abonnés payants donc le pour moi
donc j'ai deux missions ce que je disais
c'est la première c'est de réaliser des
objectifs financiers pour que le média
puisse puisse poursuivre et se
développer et l'objectif que j'ai fixé
c'est 20000 abonnés payant en fin
d'année aujourd'hui on a réussi à
atteindre la part des 10000 abonnés on a
évidemment le magazine qu'on a lancé
donc c'est un trimestriel les ventes ont
très bien fonctionné puisqu'on est à
15000 ventes kiosque et kiosque Internet
et puis la deuxième mission que j'ai
c'est sur les reportages sur lesquels je
peux être utile notamment
dans les zones dans les zones russophone
par exemple ce qu'on a réalisé un
deuxième reportage au mois de janvier
sur la ligne de front du nom de basse là
c'est d'accompagner le le journaliste en
l'occurrence c'était à nouveau Régis en
servant de de chauffeur et d'interprète
sur place voilà
merci Monsieur d'Anjou ma première
question sera faite assez simple c'est
j'aimerais comprendre le nom en fait que
vous avez choisi pour votre média
omerta c'est-à-dire la loi du silence
dans les sociétés gangrenées par la
mafia donc j'avoue puisque vous publiez
enfin puisque vous publiez se faire de
la part en France ces médias qui sont
francophones je ne comprends pas en quoi
ce terme s'applique à notre société
alors
voilà je vais voilà donc le média omerta
enfin le choix du nom vient d'un constat
c'est à dire que typiquement je viens
vous
à la fin de ma première présentation je
vous ai expliqué que nous sommes nous
passés 15 jours en Afghanistan
Afghanistan aux mains des talibans dans
lequel il est difficile d'évoluer dans
lequel il faut avoir des contacts moi
j'avais des contacts déjà parce que
j'avais déjà rencontré les talibans à
l'époque où il n'était pas au pouvoir et
aujourd'hui j'ai réactivé ses contacts
pour essayer de mettre un focus sur une
société afghane qui est dans le noir et
en particulier la question des femmes on
en entend parler de l'extérieur j'ai
également aussi pu avoir pu aller en me
rendre en Iran en octobre dernier l'idée
d'omerta c'est de de briser l'omerta
évidemment il s'agit pas de procéder
comme une société mathieuse il ne s'agit
pas tout est clair mais l'idée c'est de
d'apporter un focus sur des zones
difficiles d'accès sur des des
thématiques parfois
comment dire qu'on aimerait voir traiter
on en a fait aussi sur la question de la
transidentité on a fait un documentaire
réalisé par
Amélie menu qui est une de nos reporters
on va en faire un autre qui est
elle-même est en train d'en faire un
autre sur la question du de l'addiction
au porno c'est des phénomènes de société
dont on parle assez peu mais qui agite
nos sociétés et notre notre objectif
chez omerta justement c'est de d'aller
sur place en tout cas d'interviewer ou
d'interroger ou de donner un micro aux
gens qui sont les acteurs dans ces dans
ces divers domaines et d'essayer
d'apporter de une forme de compréhension
de ces phénomènes en l'occurrence sur la
société taliban c'est d'aller rencontrer
les femmes sur place et croyez moi c'est
compliqué on est dans des environnements
où on peut se faire traiter là on a on a
eu l'occasion de nous adresser à un des
membres du gouvernement Taliban et lui
demander quid du sort d'un de nos
collègues qui actuellement est détenu
sous des charges d'espionnage par ce
même gouvernement taliban c'est un
quelqu'un qui a été qui a servi de
fixeur pour pas mal de collègues pour
France 2 notamment et qui actuellement
est détenu sous des charges d'espionnage
nous avons donc demandé quid en disant
voilà nous notre collègue et comment est
détenu voilà ça fait partie ça ça fait
partie d'une de la communauté des
journalistes entre entre guillemets de
se défendre les uns les autres mais
c'est aussi pour le cas de l'Afghanistan
d'apporter un focus sur un pays qui
malheureusement a été un peu délaissé
alors il y a les caisses la question de
l'actualité avec la guerre en Ukraine
qui a occupé l'espace médiatique mais du
coup un certain nombre de pays comme ça
l'Éthiopie par exemple
sont de vérité ou même la Syrie sont
aujourd'hui de véritables trous noirs
médiatique et nous il nous paraît
important d'essayer en tout cas de
continuer à aller dans ces zones et à
rapporter de l'information à expliquer
ce qui s'y passe à continuer à suivre
ces mouvements et pas simplement suivre
l'actualité telle qu'elle est dictée par
une sorte de comment dire de de
mouvement qui met l'attention sur un
endroit et ensuite on passe à un autre
voilà
merci Monsieur le sommier monsieur
d'Anjou voulais ajouter quelque chose
à ajouter si ce n'est que effectivement
le on a souhaité de se saisir de
thématique qui parfois de
son pas ou ne peuvent pas être traités
par des par d'autres médias ou d'autres
journalistes
et donc effectivement le
les thématiques sont sont diverses il y
a des thématiques nationales sur donc le
walkisme le porno par exemple qui arrive
qu'il sort bientôt
également sur les migrations et les
questions de sécurité et puis sur
l'international aussi avec des grands
portages de guerre et là donc les
prochains sont donc sur l'Afghanistan et
sur le sur le Liban
avec un voyage certainement en Afrique
dans un pays aussi compliqué d'accès
je vous remercie monsieur d'Anjou est-ce
que vous pourriez nous expliquer
ce qui fait quand même l'objet de
beaucoup de commentaires dans la dans la
presse française c'est le le monte enfin
le montage le
oui la façon dont vous avez monté ce
média vous l'avez dit vous-même
d'ailleurs dans des dans des délais très
rapides le monde médiatique est assez
capitalistique c'est pas facile de
rentrer c'est un marché sur lequel il
est pas facile de pénétrer qui
aujourd'hui en tout cas pour ce qui est
de la France mais c'est vrai dans toutes
les démocratie assez concentrée donc la
concurrence est rude
ça demande un petit peu de temps pour
s'installer vous vous dites vous avez
fait des abonnements si j'ai bien
compris 10000 abonnements alors j'avais
pas bien noté le montant mais vous nous
l'indiquerez mais 4 années donc ça fait
donc ça fait une somme mais c'est vrai
qu'on peut on peut s'interroger sur sur
l'équilibre financier donc est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer
davantage le
les tenant aboutissants financiers et
juridique de votre de votre entreprise
médiatique s'il vous plaît
oui absolument alors le modèle c'est
assez simple c'est un
c'est un donc il y a une société qui est
une qui est une holding qui détient une
filiale la filiale s'appelle omerta
l'intégralité des fonds injectés donc ce
que j'ai donné ce que j'avais indiqué à
la presse c'est le budget sur un an
c'est et de 1 million d'euros donc il y
a déjà 500000 euros qui ont été versés
l'intégralité à 100% à l'euro près de
ses fonds proviennent de fonds propres
de son personnel
il n'y a pas il y a évidemment pas
un centime de comme il a pu être je
dirais
sous-entendu dans la presse d'argent
étranger
et l'objectif du média vous venez de
vous venez de le dire c'est que
comment dire le la pérennité du média
niveau de la d'un an tienne tient au
fait que on réussisse un certain nombre
d'objectifs d'abord de les abonnements
payants qui donnent accès à
l'application qui donne accès au contenu
exclusif en version longue de des
reportages des reportages qu'on produit
le deuxième c'est évidemment le magazine
papier donc
15000 exemplaires vendus ça fait
225000 euros donc c'est un support aussi
intéressant commercial intéressant qui
permet de qui permet de je dirais de
renforcer l'entreprise financièrement et
puis il y a un troisième aspect aussi
qui est je dirais absolument
stratégique pour nous
c'est l'agrément
du Ministère de la Culture
cet agrément donne le droit au cap de
presse mais aussi à une TVA réduite
et
cet agrément je l'ai intégré dans le
business model sur sur un an ça fait à
peu près 200.000 euros on est sur un on
est sur un montant de 200000 euros il y
a l'agrément et donc l'obtention de cet
agrément est tout à fait fondamental
pour la pérennité du média et je dois
souligner que compte tenu des articles
dans certains sont diffamatoires
et pour lesquels j'ai déposé plainte
notamment l'article du Monde l'article
de Libération et l'article de Télérama
et bien le ministère de la Culture a
ajourné
l'obtention de cet agrément alors que
nous remplissons toutes les conditions
pour l'obtenir
cet agrément a été à journée sur la base
et cette explicitement formulée comme ça
de l'article du Monde du mois de janvier
voilà donc
le
il y a pas d'argent sans fin pour
financer le média l'objectif il est à un
an il est à la fin de l'année le budget
il est assuré jusqu'à la fin de l'année
maintenant pour poursuivre au delà il
faut qu'on a qu'on installe nos
objectifs de qu'on est absolument cet
agrément qui est qui est qui est
absolument nécessaire pour le pour la le
développement de du média et de
l'entreprise
je vous remercie quand vous dites que
c'est un million d'euros sur vos fonds
propres donc vous vous certifiez
aujourd'hui devant cette commission
d'enquête sous serment que cet argent
provient uniquement de vos biens
personnels parce que ça peut paraître
une somme importante et c'est une somme
qui provient de vos activités
professionnelles
vous avez exercice un héritage c'est
parce que on a eu un audition avant vous
on a eu le film ma question on a eu une
audition avant vous ne monsieur de
Monsieur
le roi pardon monsieur Maurice Leroy qui
nous a dit que vous avez rencontré dans
le cadre vous étiez d'après lui
responsable de la sécurité du Roy Merlin
à Moscou donc est-ce que vous pouvez
bien qu'on comprenne ce que c'est le but
de cette commission d'enquête c'est pas
d'établir du tout le tiens à le préciser
des responsabilités pénales ou
juridiques ça peut tout l'objet c'est de
comprendre les phénomènes donc c'est
vrai qu'on aimerait par rapport à ce
qu'on lit dans la presse comprendre
comment cette somme a pu être assemblée
aussi vite surtout si c'est des fois
uniquement personnels
alors aussi vite non puisque je
travaille depuis
15 ans
donc c'est le fric 15 années de travail
Leroy Merlin j'étais salarié de Leroy
Merlin Russie pendant 6 mois c'est la
seule expérience salariée que j'ai eu de
ma vie puisque tout le 14e et demi
j'étais
j'ai exercé des activités
d'entrepreneurs
et ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est un point technique mais qui est
vérifié de très facilement c'est que
depuis le depuis 2014 la Russie est sous
sanctions
depuis le début de la guerre les banques
russes sont sous sanction et donc il est
absolument impossible d'envoyer un seul
euro depuis la Russie vers un compte en
France c'est tous ces techniquement
impossible voilà donc
me concernant j'ai des activités en
Russie j'en ai eu aussi j'en ai aussi
dans d'autres pays j'ai des sociétés en
Russie j'en ai aussi dans d'autres pays
je suis fiscalisé à l'étranger donc d'un
point de vue d'un point de vue légal et
compréhens de toute façon je n'ai tout
est tout est absolument
clair et légal et il est bien évident
que une société comme
omerta avec les fonds qui sont injectés
n'aurait pas pu comment dire exister si
il y avait eu comment dire des
des
signaux négatifs concernant l'origine
des fonds etc etc c'est tout bonnement
impossible voilà
je vous remercie la réponse qu'on va
apporter en soulève une autre question
vous avez dit effectivement avec les
sanctions les mouvements bancaires sont
extrêmement compliqués voir impossible
entre la Russie et notre pays et dans je
ne comprends pas comment sur ces fonds
propres vous avez justement depuis vos
activités russes financées des activités
en France si ces mouvements bancaires
sont si limités
mais quand vous êtes fiscalisé à
l'étranger vous pouvez détenir des
comptes en France c'est pas interdit
donc
ce que je dis c'est que quand j'ai lancé
l'argent qui provient du finance qui qui
a financé omerta ne vient pas de compte
enrichissent c'est de l'argent qui était
sur des comptes en France dont l'Union
européenne il n'y a pas de lien entre
mes activités en Russie et les
fonds qui ont été
qui ont financé
donc ce sont des des fonds que vous avez
accumulés par vos activités
professionnelles avant que vous veniez
en Russie à partir de 2006
oui ou mais après mais qui n'ont rien à
voir avec des activités professionnelles
aussi
très bien je vous remercie
une autre question qui a été soulevée
par par les les documents mais aussi de
nos recherches personnelles ce sont les
liens avec le média livre noir
média livre noir qui est apparu aussi de
manière très rapide un peu avant la
présidentielle de de
2022 pardon qui semble si mes
informations soient exactes avoir une
activité moindre depuis que la
présidentielle c'est achevé et il semble
que vous ayez partagé un local et un
certain nombre d'employés qui auraient
été transférés de l'un à l'autre est-ce
que vous pouvez nous nous expliciter vos
liens avec ce média
livre noir qui a joué un rôle non
négligeable non pas décisives enfin pas
non plus négligeable dans la
présidentielle notamment quand même dans
la couverture d'un nombre de candidats
réduits
alors vivre non je peux répondre à
certaines de vos questions mais manière
incomplète je pense qu'il faudrait
peut-être
écouter le écouter le écouter le
président ce que je peux vous dire pour
livre vraiment c'est très simple c'est
que une partie de ce qui est sorti dans
la presse est vrai c'est à dire que
j'ai
c'est un média qui est en qui a connu
une un développement assez fulgurant en
recevant des personnalités de tout bord
y compris y compris des députés
macronistes etc je pense à Madame berger
qui est allé sur le fauteuil du Livre
noir pour les grands entretiens donc
moi le je n'ai pas d'implication dans ce
média je n'en suis pas actionnaire je
contrairement à ce qui a été dit dans la
presse et ça fait d'ailleurs l'objet de
ça fait partie du contenu d'une des
plaintes je n'ai jamais fait de
proposition de rachat de livres noirs
jamais strictement jamais
la seule chose que le seul lien qui
existe c'est le la relation que j'ai
avec son président puisque il est venu
aussi après avoir fait 15 jours ou trois
semaines côté
ukrainien pendant la guerre je crois
près gitomir pas loin de Kiev et ensuite
à Odessa avec ses équipes il a souhaité
faire un reportage côté russe et donc je
l'ai rencontré pour la première fois à
doniak au mois de mars et on s'est bien
entendu on est devenu copain il y a la
situation interne de livre noir et
compliquée c'est aussi dans la presse
etc et quand il s'est agit de en général
je suis je suis fidèle en amitié et
quand je peux quand je peux aider là
c'était le cas
je le fais en général enfin quand j'en
ai les moyens quand j'en ai la
possibilité je le fais c'est ce que j'ai
fait ensuite sur le calme on n'a pas
partagé de local il se trouve que quand
j'ai créé la quand j'ai créé la société
au mois d'août il me fallait une adresse
en France pour le greffe tout simplement
et que et que Eric tenner
gentiment accepté de de comment dire de
donner son adresse personnelle qui a été
ensuite modifié puisque la société a été
créée ensuite on a les comptes bancaires
ont été ouverts j'ai pu faire les
apports en compte courant et ensuite
nous avons pris des bureaux qui
aujourd'hui
accueille l'activité qui sont aussi le
siège des deux sociétés à Boulogne
voilà c'est les seuls liens qui qu'il y
a avec
livre noir
merci beaucoup monsieur d'Anjou sauf
erreur de ma part le premier exemplaire
première édition pardon du la version
magazine d'oberta était consacré à la
guerre en Ukraine est-ce que vous
pourriez pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
fait ce choix alors au-delà évidemment
du fait évidemment que c'est une
actualité importante et qu'on célèbre
malheureusement le premier anniversaire
de cette de cette guerre
pourquoi ce quoi pour ce premier ce
premier magazine d'autant plus qu'on
peut par rapport à la réponse que j'ai
compris monsieur le sommier que c'est
pas spécialement une zone qui n'est pas
couverte ou qui relève de des doublis de
comment dire du zapping du zapping
d'actualité et de l'oubli qui peut
caractériser certains effectivement au
Théâtre des guerres que vous avez cité
l'Afghanistan le Yémen Éthiopie
mais que bon pour le coup ne manque pas
de de nature pas assez d'informations
mais en tout cas on peut pas dire que
c'est pas une zone qui couverte donc
pourquoi ce soir et comment est-ce que
aussi quel choix en tant que
professionnel vous avez estimé faire sur
la ligne éditoriale
alors le le magazine omerta en fait il
contient un reportage oui en effet qui
lui par contre est rare c'est un
reportage de ce point de vue côté russe
sur le front nord de backmouth dans une
zone qui s'appelle criminas va Tovo
là par contre il y a peu de reportages
qui ont été réalisés côté russe
Charles d'Anjou a cité ceux qui ont été
réalisés par TF1 au début de la guerre
par liseron boudoule il y a quelques
correspondants de France 2 je crois et
du Figaro qui sont venus côté russe mais
c'est extrêmement difficile et
extrêmement compliqué de d'avoir les
accès beaucoup plus que côté ukrainien
ça c'est une vérité donc ce reportage ce
magazine contenait un reportage que j'ai
fait moi-même avec les critères que
j'applique dans tous mes reportages
c'est à dire
une certaine distance une certaine et en
même temps à côté humain c'est-à-dire de
d'essayer de comprendre ce qui motive
les combattants en l'occurrence puisque
nous sommes allés en première ligne avec
un groupe enfin une bataillon nous avons
passé une dizaine de jours avec eux
au-delà de ça le magazine et l'idée du
magazine Elle est venue pour une raison
simple
le titre on est
Ukraine la vérité qui dérange pourquoi
la vérité qui dérange s'agit pas de
rassembler l'idée n'était pas du tout de
rassembler des propos de de
prorus ou de très orienté mais on a
constaté que ayant invité un certain
nombre de personnalités à venir
s'entretenir avec moi notamment dans ce
que j'appelle dans ce qui s'appelle le
grand entretien qui est hebdomadaire
chez omerta et bien nous avons eu des
gens comme Pierre connaissa Maurice
gourde montagne
Henri Guaino Arnaud clarsfeld qui me
sont venus chez omertac qui sont allés
chez d'autres mais que nous disposions
d'une matière assez intéressante que
nous avons souhaité compiler dans ce
magazine pour présenter un petit peu un
point de vue je dirais
alternatif à la guerre en Ukraine
c'est-à-dire des gens qui dans leur
domaine particulier avaient des choses à
dire un petit peu autre que ce qu'on
entend malheureusement sur certaines
chaînes qui est un peu répétitif et un
peu toujours dans le même sens
l'idée c'était de pouvoir tendre tant
avec Jacques beau par exemple dans le
monde du renseignement ou avec Bernard
squarsini que nous avons aussi qui fait
qui est dans ce dans ce magazine
Michel Onfray il y en a plein d'autres
chacun dans leur domaine et essayons de
porter son regard dans la guerre en
Ukraine ça nous paraissait important
justement de réunir ses voix dans un
magazine et je pense que le succès de ce
magazine est lié à ça c'est une pure
opportunité d'une idée qui est pas très
originale mais qui a fonctionné parce
que un certain nombre de Français ont
acheté ce magazine parce que ils ont ils
avaient besoin de lire autre chose
peut-être que ce qu'on leur proposait
dans d'autres médias
merci Monsieur donc je vous avais une un
complément à apporter
ce qui est intéressant c'est que
je pense que c'est un point de vue
complémentaire l'analyse de ce qui se
passe en Ukraine et ce qui est avec la
qualité des intervenants qui ont
contribué aux grands entretiens et puis
ensuite au magazine je pense que ça
donne
au lecteur une
vision à 360 degrés d'un problème qui
est d'un gestion d'actualité qui est
brûlante moi j'étais assez sidéré si
vous voulez sur le
du parfois du
[Musique]
du traitement malhonnête de certaines
données liées à la guerre en Ukraine
j'ai fait pas mal parce que j'ai sorti
aussi un livre avec ils ont boudoul aux
éditions l'Observatoire sur la sur la
bataille de Mario Paul et j'étais invité
pendant quatre mois sur LCI et parfois
le niveau de l'argumentation
que ce soit du côté de
prorus
friselle la malhonnêteté ou le
naïveté confondante et ce qu'on offre
avec les reportages sur n'importe quel
sujet d'ailleurs quel qu'il soit et le
magazine c'est je dirais des paroles de
des paroles d'experts reconnus et pas de
la et pas de la comment dire de la de
l'émotion ou de la ou du parti pris ou
de la propagande c'est vraiment de
l'analyse de l'analyse d'expert qui est
comme disait Régis vu le succès du
magazine vraisemblablement il y a une
attente le prochain magazine sera sur
une autre thématique qui n'a rien à voir
sur une thématique nationale il y a
vraiment une attente
concernant ce genre de contenu
je vous remercie passe à part la madame
la rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président messieurs
bonjour
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
l'accueil réservé à omerta et peut-être
même réservé avant même commerçant ne
soit définitivement lancé à travers une
soirée de lancement
qui a eu un certain retentissement et
est un accueil que vous estimez
certainement extrêmement
malhonnête mal intentionnée mais qui est
néanmoins à prendre en considération
dans le cadre des travaux d'une
commission d'enquête de la solationale
consacrée aux ingérences étrangères nous
ne sommes pas
en charge de travailler sur la liberté
de la presse en France ou la manière
dont les différents médias a commencé
par les nouveaux médias qui se créent
présente les choses mais nous
travaillons sur
sujet d'ingérence étrangère donc
d'influence d'interférences d'ingérence
et la manière dont il peut y avoir en
France
sont-ils bien intentionnés ou sont-ils
mal intentionnés des
relais d'opinion des journalistes des
médias des sénates des officines des
fondations des cinq tanks des
personnalités des experts même pour
certains qui
relayent appuie soutiennent propage et
présente d'une certaine manière telle ou
telle actualité c'est à cet égard que
nous nous intéressons à
omerta qui est apparu rapidement dans le
paysage médiatique français notamment
peu de temps après la fermeture de RT et
de et de Spoutnik et qui a je dirais
d'emblée en tout cas dans ce qui est la
conception de ce que je crois être la
conception de la ligne éditoriale à
savoir un média altern qui présente ou
qui souhaitent présenter des choses
alternatives aux médias mainstream
quelques ressemblances avec ce qui était
la ligne éditoriale officielle en tout
cas telle que la
portée les responsable de de RT
notamment à être toujours dans un média
alternatif au mainstream pour présenter
des choses différemment voilà donc voilà
donc notre sujet alors vous nous avez
notamment monsieur d'Anjou en commençant
à répondre à des questions posées par
Monsieur le Président dit de trois
choses sur sur le financement je vous
cache pas qu'il y a quand même peut-être
n'est pas été suffisamment attentif mais
encore peut-être quelques quelques
moments d'imprécision
vous dites que ce sont des fonds propres
donc vous parlez d'un million mais en
même temps vous avez écrit sur votre
site que c'était 500 000 que vous avez
injecté 500
000 euros pardon de fonds propres donc
de fond qui préviennent de votre fortune
personnelle que vous avez injecté dans
le média
alors est-ce que c'est parce qu'il y a
une répartition entre ce que vous avez
mis dans la société de production Norman
et
omerta 500 000 d'un côté 500000 de
l'autre enfin voilà il est parce qu'il y
a eu des versions un peu différentes qui
ont qui ont circulé y compris dans des
écrits que vous avez fait donc voilà je
voulais avoir quelques présidents pour
être sûr que cela est bien compris et
qui a pas de zone d'ombre encore une
fois voilà c'est juste pour voilà faire
vous avez dit que tout est clair faire
faire la clarté je voulais aussi savoir
que c'est important ça pour comprendre
comment vous avez budgété les les frais
de fonctionnement d'omerta pour pour
l'année en cours combien de personnes
sont salariés combien de personnes sont
consultants enfin voilà comment vous
faites fonctionner le média et et quels
sont voilà les différents postes
budgétaires notamment celui consacré à
la rémunération des journalistes et eux
qu'ils soient salariés ou freelance au
pigiste voilà c'était mes
mes premières questions
alors le budget pour être très clair le
budget pour un an et d'un million
d'euros
je l'ai précisé je crois que c'était la
Lettre de l'Expansion au moment du
lancement du média quand j'ai parlé de
500.000 euros c'est la somme qui a été
dépensé au bout de 6 mois donc
comment dire CTA un point d'étape
financier en disant que la moitié de la
somme
budgétait pour le un an de
fonctionnement du média au
fonctionnement en prenant enfin je
dirais la location des bureaux l'achat
du matériel le paiement des salaires etc
c'est un million d'euros la somme qui a
été donc utilisée dépenser au bout de 6
mois c'est 500.000 euros donc de ce
point de vue là le les chiffres sont les
mêmes en fait simplement c'était un
point d'étape quand on m'a posé la
question j'ai répondu 500 000 ça
correspondait à un point d'étape
financier au bout de six mois le
aujourd'hui dans omerta omerta et
l'équipe de Martha c'est
[Musique]
20 20 personnes avec pour moitié des
salariés et pour moitié des alternants
ou des CDI donc le la charge les charges
d'omerta par mois sont je crois autour
de 50000 euros voilà auquel il faut
ajouter la location des bureaux et les
frais de les frais de comment dire de
liés au reportages qui soient sur le
territoire national ou à l'étranger
voilà sur le modèle financier par
exemple on n'avait pas quand j'ai quand
j'ai conçu le
business model modèle financier du média
j'avais pas intégré par exemple le
magazine le magazine c'est une idée
qu'on qui a germé comme Régis l'a dit
à la suite des en grands entretiens
qu'on a réalisé avec des personnalités
on a eu cette idée du magazine en se
disant
le 24 février arrive c'est
l'anniversaire de enfin c'est la
première année de la guerre en Ukraine
et donc il serait intéressant comme l'a
fait d'ailleurs je crois L'Express avec
Bernard et Lévy d'avoir un magazine
sur le sujet à ce moment-là voilà
faire un magazine au mois de mois de
juin sur l'Ukraine n'aurait pas eu de
sens par contre fin février ça avait du
sens commercialement commercialement
c'était on a on a c'est une opération
qui a été réussie et qui vient qui vient
conforter financièrement le évidemment
le média
d'accord
donc acte voilà ça sera porté à la
connaissance des uns et des autres bien
sûr chacun pourra
méditer
cela
s'agissant de la ligne éditoriale donc
ce sont des documentaires dans un
premier temps ça a été très clairement
dit tant par vous que par Monsieur le
sommier
et puis vous avez également donc des
documentaires côté russe des
documentaires sur
[Musique]
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la par la
Russie donc cette région du monde et
cette thématique là si je puis dire
ça vous a valu d'ailleurs je crois
monsieur d'Anjou d'être invité par une
une chaîne de télévision qui est je
crois proche si ce n'est pas d'ailleurs
totalement intégré à l'armée russe qui
qui vous a je crois rendu hommage en
quelque sorte j'essaye de retrouver
exactement ce que moi je ne parle pas
russe le nom de cette chaîne je crois
que c'était le premier décembre 20 22
contrairement à vous je ne parle pas
russe le premier décembre 20 22 voilà
c'est ça je crois que vous avez été
invité par la chaîne de télévision du
ministère la défense enfin c'est ce que
j'ai trouvé comme information qui
s'appelle da et qui vous a complémenté
justement sur le documentaire front
russe qui manifestement à l'heure de
plaire au ministère de de la Défense
russe mais vous avez également déjà
annoncé vous l'avez écrit vous-même sur
sur votre site que vous aviez
l'intention de vous pencher sur d'autres
sujets
je reprends mot pour mot
les délires walk
les le scandale du laxisme migratoire
voilà je j'apprends ces sujets là
et vous revendiquez d'être un média
national français patriotes mais non
soumis à l'état actuel je pense que vous
voulez dire l'état français tout cela
est parfaitement légitime et dans un
État de droit nul ne serait trouvé à y
redire mais je pense simplement que
c'est important que en toute
transparence sans pratiquer d'omerta
donc sans loi du silence en toute
transparence des choses soient assumées
donc sur un positionnement qui est par
ailleurs à travers certains alors moi je
ne suis pas abonné à omerta donc je n'ai
pas regardé l'intégralité de vos
documentaires mais on a pu en voir
certains extraits qui est quand même
souvent très pro russe il faut dire les
choses comme elles sont y compris dans
le cadre du conflit actuellement mené
par par la Fédération de Russie et
contre la rue l'Ukraine voilà c'est je
pense ainsi que ça a été ressenti par
beaucoup des personnes qui ont qui ont
gardé notamment certains documentaires
voilà c'était juste alors comment
qu'avez-vous à la radiation je vois que
Monsieur le sommier réagit donc monsieur
le Président merci de la rapporteur
monsieur le sommier
oui vous avez cité je voulais reprendre
vos propos au début vous avez cité un
émoi dans la presse française au moment
enfin en tout cas retentissement moi je
note tout simplement que en dehors de
libération du monde de Mediapart et de
Télérama c'est-à-dire en gros la même
sphère idéologique il n'y a pas eu des
mois dans la presse en France général ni
de lever de bouclier concernant omerta
voilà ça c'est le premier point ensuite
sur la question du traitement puisque
vous expliquer que les Russes se sont
penchés sur notre documentaire front
russe je vais en décrire quand même un
petit peu le contenu je pense être le
seul journaliste à l'époque présent dans
la ville de Kerson à qui on a présenté
pour les Russes évidemment qui
occupaient la ville nous ont présenté un
certain nombre de manuels scolaires des
nouveaux manuels qui a été qui ont été à
destination des Oblates conquis par
russe je pense être le seul journaliste
avoir pu l'opportunité en tout cas
l'avoir fait le consulter ses
documentaires c'est c'est nouveau
manuels la destination de la jeunesse
ukrainienne puisque il s'agit du crâne
et de noter que la question de
l'odomorph était
relativisé entre en tout cas voir
intégrer à l'histoire russe et d'avoir
posé cette question et donc dans le
documentaire on peut le consulter on
voit l'embarras de cette professeur de
la directrice de l'école qui nous disent
mais avant oui avant de commencer était
elles vont dans l'arrière boutique elles
nous ressortent le livre dans lequel
consacrait à la donc à la grande famille
perpétrée par Staline qui est quand même
un acte
je dirais qui dans la mémoire
ukrainienne est très marquante et nous
expliquer que donc avant oui c'était
comme ça donc on peut alors dire que
c'est un documentaire prorus
excusez-moi je tombe je tombe de ma
chaise non non mais si qui était jugé et
c'est toujours en fait c'est toujours
des approximations on entend toujours
des choses mais les gens ne regardent
pas ce qu'on fait ils n'ont pas été voir
ce documentaire et ce documentaire en
tout en étant journaliste en essayant
j'essaye toujours d'apporter du
contradictoire et c'est toujours de
poser des questions des questions
importantes des questions sur les Russes
pourquoi vous êtes là vous combattez
pourquoi des questions essentielles
finalement et ça ça a toujours été mon
métier le problème c'est que aujourd'hui
cette description un peu sommaire de
omerta media prorus fait l'économie
totale de ce que nous faisons au par
ailleurs de par ailleurs vous avez quand
même souligné que nous faisons autre
chose je suis quand même étonné que
je suis prêt à parier avec vous que si
quand notre documentaire sortira sur
l'Afghanistan personne ne va me dire
vous êtes complice des tal
mais je suis allé chez les talibans
alors faut-il aller chez les talibans
comme faut-il aller chez les Russes ça
c'est toute une question et moi je
connais beaucoup de confrères qui
travaillent dans les médias dit
mainstream dans lesquels j'ai travaillé
aussi et qui considère qu'il faut
continuer à découvrir quand on peut le
faire l'autre côté qu'on ne peut pas se
contenter d'une seule couverture
monsieur le Président tout à l'heure
vous avez dit qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
reportages fait côté ukrainien il faut
qu'on puisse comprendre ce qui se passe
côté russe en appliquant des règles
strictes du reportage qui ont toujours
été mon light motiv au cours de ma vie
j'ai d'ailleurs passé beaucoup plus de
temps avec l'armée américaine qui est
l'armée russe dans mon passé j'ai
toujours appliqué ces principes parfois
quitte à ne pas me faire réinviter ou
parfois en y allant contre ma conscience
j'ai découvert en septembre 2020 la
guerre au okaraba pas côté arménien mais
côté azerbaïdjanais
je suis évidemment il y a eu des
polémiques sur cet article ils auront
boudoul d'ailleurs avait ouvert le même
côté moi mon cœur il battait plus du
côté arménien Paris Match ayant présenté
un certain nombre de reportages côtés
arménien il me paraissait légitime
d'aller voir ce qui se passait de
l'autre côté ce qui ne veut absolument
pas dire on cautionne mais on explique
on y va on voit et on essaye de
comprendre et ça c'est tout ce qui m'a
motivé et c'est ce qui continue à me
motiver dans ce que je fais dans mes
reportages et je vous encourage à
regarder celui sur l'Afghanistan parce
que là c'est pareil on est toujours dans
une dans une marge très étroite je vous
ai expliqué ce qui se passait en
Afghanistan ce confrère qui est accusé
d'espionnage c'est très facile d'accuser
quelqu'un d'espionnage dans ces pays-là
en Iran pareil au moment où j'y étais
deux professeurs français ont été
détenus et ils ont fait une vidéo de
confession comme quoi ils étaient
espions etc etc donc c'est extrêmement
compliqué et quand on vient chez nous si
vous voulez moi j'ai commencé ma
carrière à par image quand je couvrais
l'Irak on revenait on entendait nos
confrères parler de nos reportages nous
féliciter ou ne pas en parler et puis ça
se passait comme ça aujourd'hui quand
même un problème c'est qu'on va couvrir
ces conflits-là où on risque notre peau
je peux vous dire que la ligne de front
de backmouth vous emmenez pas large et
qu'on vous passez 10 jours là-bas c'est
une un véritable traumatisme en revenant
donc quand vous passez du temps sur le
terrain et qu'en plus vous faites
flinguer par des gens qui ne bougent pas
leur siège ici et je voulais je tenais à
citer quand même quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup choqué j'ai regardé un certain
nombre de débats que mon qui ont été
enfin de d'audition et l'autre jour j'ai
vu monsieur Nicolas tanzère qui était
auditionné ici m'accusé d'être un agent
russe voilà j'étais un agent russe ça a
été bon et j'ai fait mes recherches et
je suis allé regarder qui était ce
Nicolas Tanzer et je constate en lisant
sa fiche Wikipédia qu'en 2022 il a
rejoint le CEP le centre Center for your
open policy and I this un institut de
recherche à but non lucratif et non
partisans créé en 2005 à Washington
dédié à l'étude de l'Europe centrale et
orientale une institution d'influence
américaine qui se vous à travailler une
alliance transatlantique forte et
durable enracinée dans les valeurs
démocratiques les principes
démocratiques voilà donc cette
personne-là
me traite des gens russe lui avez-vous
posé la question par qui est-il question
qui vous voulez ailleurs qu'à la
commission d'enquête monsieur le sommier
cette commission d'enquête ne vise pas à
mettre en cause des personnes les gens
portent un témoignage c'est la
commission souverainement il y a si
c'est nécessaire un vote retient un
certain nombre d'information qui
personne de procéder à d'autres
auditions
à ne pas procéder aux auditions monsieur
teneur a porté un témoignage nous
l'avons interrogé d'ailleurs moi-même je
crois que j'ai interrogé sur un certain
nombre de choses mais ce n'est pas à
vous de remettre en cause le travail de
la commission vous répondez à vos
questions je vous remercie mais nous
faisons nous-mêmes notre travail de
parlementaire et une fois plus que je le
dis cette commission d'enquête visa
informé la représentation nationale et
nos concitoyens elle ne vise pas à
mettre en cause des personnes ce n'est
pas notre vocation et encore moins nos
attributions constitutionnelles madame
le rapporteur est-ce que vous avez une
réponse à votre question
oui on peut dire ça aussi mais j'ai une
autre question
peut-être alors cette fois-ci adressée
plus particulièrement à Monsieur d'Anjou
et là encore
vous allez
considérer que
ou monsieur le sommier les choses et les
informations que nous pouvons lire dans
les médias vous concernant concernant
omerta ou d'autres activités proviennent
toujours du même cercle je reprends
l'expression que vous avez pris mais en
même temps
d'une part ce cercle là existe et puis
d'autre part il y a des informations
dont nous pouvons
avoir connaissance selon d'autres
sources et que nous ne pouvons pas par
exemple citer donc il nous arrive de
citer ce que nous lisons dans la presse
par exemple parce que ça ça peut être
cité voilà et c'est public et c'est
intéressant que que les gens le sachent
et surtout ça peut être cité sans
crainte alors il y a une affaire
monsieur d'Anjou qu'on pourrait appeler
livraison de drones et qui concerne
une sombre à faire de
diminante livraison de matériel de
construction de drone
[Musique]
à propos de cette annonce imminente de
livraison de matériel qui est encore une
fois n'était pas autorisé à être livré à
ces République auto proclamé
alors
j'ai donné une conférence aux cigare
club de Moscou effectivement sur le la
bataille de Mario Paul
[Musique]
le j'étais invité
ce qui a été rapporté
dans la il faut savoir que après en fait
cette cette conférence
je ne suis pas retourné dans le monde de
donc les éléments qui ont été rapportés
par la presse sont faux ça fait
d'ailleurs l'objet d'une partie de la
plainte contre Télérama
preuve à l'appui puisque j'ai été j'ai
demandé liseron Boudou les redescendus
dans le don de basse pour couvrir la fin
de la bataille de Mario Paul et quand
j'ai demandé le renouvellement de les
actualités pour pouvoir descendre je
suis le seul à qui les accréditations
ont été refusées ça j'ai l'épreuve
écrite certifiée par huissier qui font
qui sont dans la plate
et qui
atteste que j'ai tout simplement été
interdit de don de basse de territoires
prorus pendant trois mois et au mois de
septembre quand nous réalisons le
reportage de trois semaines
Régis le sommier entre dans le nom de
masse seul parce que tout simplement je
ne peux pas y entrer voilà donc cette
histoire de drone est fausse le
compte-rendu qui a été fait de cette
réunion du cigare club faut savoir que
la cigare club de Moscou ce sont des
Russes c'était le j'étais invité en tant
que Français parce que j'avais découvert
la bataille de Mario Paul et que vous
voulez avoir le
récit ce qu'on avait ce qu'on avait vu
mais l'essentiel de ce club enfin la
major l'intégralité du club est russe
donc leurs activités
je ne suis pas membre du club
leurs activités ne me regarde pas ce qui
décide de faire avant après ne me
regarde absolument pas moi j'étais une
conférence je n'ai jamais livré de drone
le journaliste qui a écrit ce papier la
crise sans aucune preuve par contre moi
j'ai les preuves que je ne suis pas
retournée dans le bombasse et que mes
accréditations étaient refusés voilà
donc c'est un à la fois sur la base les
je constate que les Russes parfois de
toute façon vous le voyez avec la guerre
le les chaînes comme elle sait le montre
suffisamment les Russes sont
manquent souvent de sont souvent dans
l'approximation et comment dire
c'est pas j'irai des professionnels de
l'organisation et de la il manque de
discipline disons voilà mais me
concernant les choses sont absolument
claires le journaliste de Télérama en
dehors de jeter le soupçon sur moi comme
ils l'ont fait d'ailleurs avant le
lancement du média n'a strictement
aucune preuve de ce qu'il avance voilà
par contre moi j'ai toutes les preuves
je pense pour pouvoir le faire condamner
là dessus j'ajoute pour revenir à votre
question précédente que le
en fait vous savez ce qui est terrible
c'est que le premier article
contromerta est sorti avant le lancement
d'omerta c'est à dire avant le que le
journaliste qu'il a écrit ait pu
visionner nos trois premières portages
et pourquoi ça a été fait en fait il y a
deux le journaliste parlait de cercle
etc les médias il y a une éditoriale
dans les médias en France on sait très
bien comme partout dans le monde le les
médias qui comment dire nous écrivent
sur nous ne sont pas nombreux mais à
chaque fois l'angle est toujours le même
c'est-à-dire que effectivement c'est le
on serait prorus on serait des agents
russes on serait de la propagande on
serait financé par la Russie sans
apporter la moindre preuve de ce qu'ils
avancent la moindre preuve la moindre
preuve par contre je pense que
l'objectif est très clair c'est que en
fait ce qui dérange c'est
pas tellement le traitement du conflit
russe puisque si vous regardez les
documentaires je suis prêt à vous les
envoyer
si vous souhaitez les regarder sans être
abonné je vous laisserai parvenir ce
sont des reportages factuels c'est du
factuel c'est une vision à 360 degrés de
ce qui se passe sur le terrain il y a
pas de absolument pas d'idéologie ou
politique par contre le
fait de traiter des questions de la
transidentité
c'est pour les médias qui nous attaquent
totalement insupportable pourquoi parce
que sur la question du walkisme et de la
transidentité on donne effectivement une
analyse avec des psychiatres avec des
parents d'enfants ayant changé de sexe
etc une vision à 360 degrés qui peut
effectivement critiquer le la manière
dont est présenté la transidentité dans
un certain nombre de médias donc ça ça
ne leur plaît pas il y a des sujets qui
devraient leur être réservés les sujets
de société qui devraient leur être
réservés qu'on soit qui est un média qui
porte peut-être une autre une autre
vision une autre analyse leur est
totalement insupportable et qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont trouvé pour attaquer le média
c'est pas tellement le contenu des
reportages puisque si vous regardez le
contenu des papiers qui sont qui comment
dire qui nous attaquent porte ne porte
quasiment jamais sur le contenu des
reportage il porte toujours sur le fait
que Régis est travaillé pendant 6 mois
pour RT France et le fait que j'ai
travaillé en Russie alors que j'ai
travaillé aussi en Ukraine j'ai
travaillé dans plein de pays dans le
monde
voilà c'est l'angle d'attaque qui a été
choisi pour descendre le média mais pas
pour
pas je pense uniquement sur le
traitement qu'on fait de la guerre en
Ukraine mais sur l'ensemble des
thématiques et la manière dont on
travaille sur l'ensemble des thématiques
qu'on couvre y compris d'ailleurs
l'immigration de la sécurité etc voilà
oui j'ai une dernière question vous nous
avez dit Monsieur d'Anjou que vous étiez
fiscalement domicilié à l'étranger donc
vous résidez à l'étranger vous pouvez
nous dire dans quel pays vous résidez
s'il vous plaît
à Dubaï d'accord donc c'est là que vous
êtes également au domicilié fiscalement
oui merci
merci de me le rapporteur madame gente
s'il vous plaît
merci monsieur le président
ajouter député
pour une circonscription je suppose
monsieur d'Anjou connais fort bien à
vous écouter une première réaction me
vient puisque vous avez nié notamment
monsieur Lefa vous avez par des paniers
vous avez réagi vivement au fait que
finalement vous puissiez être avoir été
qualifié avec omerta de médias d'opinion
or en France heureusement on peut avoir
les opinions qu'on veut peut porter les
opinions qu'on veut dans un tas de droit
et donc il me semble que être amiad
d'opinion c'est pas un délit c'est pas
un crime c'est pas un problème donc j'ai
noté votre votre envie de défendre avec
vigueur le fait que vous faisiez des tas
de reportage et d'être sujet en essayant
d'avoir une ce que vous appeliez votre
propre éthique journalistique mais donc
ma question c'est pourquoi est-ce que
vous finalement quel serait le problème
à être un média pro russe avoir des
envies de défendre un point de vue qui
est un autre point de vue
voilà est-ce que donc ma question c'est
ce que vous avez pardonnez-moi le je
vais un petit jeter un petit peu un
petit peu forte mais est-ce que vous
avez envie de dissimuler pourquoi vous
avez envie de dissimuler parce que vous
avez honte de vos idées est-ce que vous
avez besoin de répondre à quelqu'un qui
fait pression sur vous pour vous
demander surtout dis pas que tu nous
défends voilà de ça ce serait déjà ma
première question
alors oui il existe des médias de
pignons
il existe mais personnellement je ne
partage pas cette vision du journaliste
je vous le dis les médias d'opinion sont
guidés par des gens qui sont pour moi
des militants plus que des journalistes
je sais que le concept de journaliste
militants existent enfin il a été il
était popularisé personnellement je
pense que ce sont de termes qui sont
antinomiques on ne peut pas être les
deux sont respectables les deux
activités sont respectables mais elles
sont contradictoires puisque quand on
est militant on a tendance à embellir la
cause ou la personnalité pour laquelle
on milite à y voir que du positif et à
gommer le négatif en tant que
journaliste on doit être capable de dire
des choses désagréables à propos de gens
dont on peut avoir des convictions on
doit avoir des conditions je pense mais
quand on fait l'exercice de journaliste
il faut pouvoir prendre le recul et et
être capable de dire des choses
désagréables je vous citer un exemple de
l'eau de mort tout à l'heure c'est un
exemple fondamental il s'agir qu'on
touche au cœur de l'identité ukrainienne
et je confronte ces professeurs russes
sur des manuels scolaires je précise que
c'est vraiment un exemple parfait pour
ça parce que la vraie question n'est pas
de savoir si on cache quelque chose ou
si on aurait une opinion pro russe on
n'est pas une on n'a pas avoir une
opinion prose pour moi quand je fais un
reportage je vais avec des gens je ne
défends pas un camp je ne suis pas un
militant voilà et pour moi il existe des
médias d'opinion d'ailleurs il y a un
magasin journal qui s'appelle l'opinion
qui fait de de comment d'un certain
nombre de
deditoriaux il y a un éditorialisation
la presse française ça existe attends
moi j'ai défend une presse en tout cas
une vision du journaliste qui est plus
peut-être à l'anglo-saxonne
je respecte énormément la presse
américaine je la lis et je remarque
d'ailleurs que dans la presse américaine
on trouve des choses y compris sur la
question du conflit en Ukraine qu'on ne
trouve pas dans la presse française en
ce moment on est en pleine ébullition
vous savez pour la avec près la
publication de ces des fameux documents
classés top secret du Pentagone qui
révèle quand même une vision du conflit
ukrainien un peu différente de celle
qu'on a vu dans la plupart des médias
donc là il y a une vraie retour de la
réalité et la presse américaine certains
médias ont fait leur mais à culpa et le
New York Time suit par exemple toujours
un exemple que j'ai vécu à New York et
c'est un journal qui est qui m'est cher
le New York Times s'il y a toujours même
si le New York Times peut a pu
apparaître pour la guerre en Ukraine
extrêmement pro-ukrainien mais il y a
toujours ce souci de réalité et ce souci
il est dicté par l'impératif du factuel
et non pas de l'imagination et non pas
de ce qu'on souhaiterait finalement on
n'écrit pas pour ce qu'on souhaiterait
on écrit pour décrire la réalité alors
si la réalité devient dérangeante là on
entre dans une autre catégorie moi je
préfère rester dans la catégorie de ceux
qui analysent la réalité et c'est ce que
j'ai toujours fait dans ma vie et ce que
je continuerai à faire
un complément à apporter à la question
d'un
non enfin je pense avoir répondu
en partie dans ma réponse précédente
après
j'y souscris à 100%
. merci monsieur le Président donc juste
pour l'Union pas il a simplement fait
témoigner une seulement une seule source
pour le moment et on attend la manière
journalistique de confondre deux sources
avant de pouvoir confirmer l'information
ça c'était pour New York Times deuxième
question je crois que le 17 novembre
dernier vous avez organisé une soirée de
lancement pour votre nouveau média votre
magazine omerta dans le 15e
arrondissement de Paris une soirée de
lancement à laquelle plusieurs étaient
rapportés nous avons témoignages
plusieurs cadres et élus ou ancien
candidats du rassemblement national
pourriez-vous nous donner les noms des
personnes qui étaient présentes à cet
événement
en fait cette soirée de lancement
elle s'est organisée dans des conditions
particulières puisque nous avions
réservé et payé le Grand Rex puis le
théâtre du Gymnase et que
comment dire nous avons subi deux
annulations de salles sur pression de
groupe de lobby
LGBT qui ne souhaitait pas qui ont tout
fait pour que le documentaire ne soit
pas projeté donc nous avons trouvé cette
salle en 48 heures c'est la seule
l'option qui nous restait pour pouvoir
lancer le média et
cette soirée était en accès libre c'est
à dire que pouvait s'inscrire
c'était payant d'ailleurs je crois je me
souviens plus exactement du prix mais je
pourrais vous le retrouver mais pouvez
venir en fait qui voulait c'est-à-dire
que suffisait de s'inscrire je crois de
payer je me souviens plus de la Somme et
on pouvait accéder à la soirée sans
en toute liberté ce qui a été le cas
aussi pour la presse nous n'avons pas
filtré les
les journalistes les médias qui ont pu
assister au lancement elles ont pour
laquelle il y avait notamment
le journaliste du Monde qui a écrit
l'article dont je faisais référence tout
à l'heure mais aussi la lettre enfin un
certain nombre de Mediapart aussi je
crois tout le monde était accepté donc
c'était c'était tout à fait ouvert qui a
eu des
personnalités de partis politiques que
ce soit du rassemblement national des
républicains etc c'est tout à fait leurs
droits je vous dis l'accès était libre
donc il y avait pas de il y avait pas de
filtrage particulier à l'entrée la
seule crainte qu'on avait était je
dirais tentative de de
sabotage ou d'agit propre devant la
salle de la part des groupes qui nous
avaient fait annuler les deux premières
salles c'était le seul c'était le seul
risque qu'on avait identifié pour le
reste pouvait venir absolument qui
voulait
merci j'aurais aimé comme vice-prés de
la commission d'enquête que vous
puissiez me donner quelques noms je vais
passer une troisième question vous avez
fondé le sac talleyran une association
dont le but est de promouvoir les
échanges économiques culturels et
politiques franco-russe alors première
question j'ai plusieurs questions très
précises la première vous confirmer que
vous avez
fondé cette cette association
deuxièmement qui est qui sont les
membres de cette action notamment le
bureau de l'administration déjà de
l'association pardon et et combien de
membres vous avez aujourd'hui quel est
le montant de l'adhésion à cette
association est-ce que vous avez à nous
fournir éventuellement le règlement pas
le réglement intérieur là déclaration de
documents de déclaration de cette
association et nous citer les activités
que vous avez quelques-unes des
activités que vous avez pu organiser
avec cette association il y a quelle
date j'ai oublié de vous demander la
date à laquelle a été fondée
alors cette association elle elle a
existé entre en 2010 et 2011
toute activité après
quelle était l'idée quand j'ai fait mes
études à Paris 2 j'ai bénéficié d'un
programme d'échange avec les États-Unis
qui s'appelle la bourse Tocqueville mon
dossier qui ont été retenu j'ai passé un
mois à Washington au cœur des thinks
américains du Parti conservateur de la
mouvance
nos conservatrice mais aussi dans des
universités comme John Hopkins dans
différents dans différents comment dire
[Musique]
cercle organisation avec des tendances
politiques
doctrinales très diverses et en 2010 me
vient l'idée de pouvoir
faire aussi un échange entre entre
russes et français et c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'organise
le cercle Talleyrand l'association qui
réalise un voyage de part et d'autre une
délégation de
jeunes actifs russes seront à Paris
pendant 15 jours et elle rencontre un
certain nombre de personnalités
politiques
de droite mais pas que puisqu'ils ont
rencontré par exemple
Jean-Louis Bianco au Bourbon à côté de
l'Assemblée avec un échange très
intéressant donc
l'idée étant de leur expliquer un petit
peu comment fonctionne
la vie politique la vie parlementaire
ils ont été reçus à l'UMP etc à l'époque
etc enfin c'était c'était pas facile à
organiser mais c'était c'était très
intéressant je précise aussi qu'il y
avait pas de il y avait pas de
financement extérieur c'est à dire que
contrairement à la Bourse Tocqueville ou
en fait le voyage nous était offert là
les participants devaient eux-mêmes
financer leur voyage acheter leur billet
d'avion prendre leurs hôtels etc il y
avait donc pas de financement le bureau
de l'association si je me souviens bien
mais je retrouve
comprenez deux autres personnes
des Français
habitant à Paris à l'époque Monsieur si
je me souviens bien bertheina et
Monsieur lassos une vie que la sauce
et le on a également fait un voyage de
français à Moscou avec un peu moins de
succès parce que le niveau auquel on
avait accès à Moscou était pas était pas
le même n'avait pas le on avait pas le
même niveau que d'accès que qu'à Paris
il faut savoir qu'à Paris
à l'époque la délégation de russe a été
reçue à l'UMP par
Monsieur Frédéric Lefebvre si je me
souviens bien et puis monsieur Cesari
enfin ils avaient eu un vraiment un
programme de vraiment de très grande
qualité
à Moscou on a eu moins de moins de
succès on avait plutôt vraiment des
troisième ou quatrième couteau je dirais
donc voilà et tout simplement en
l'expérience s'est arrêtée puisque le
1 mois ça me prenait beaucoup de temps
et
j'avais plus enfin ça devait compliqué
et de
la majorité à l'époque a changé
c'est François Hollande qui a été élu et
il devenait compliqué autant j'avais des
accès à l'UMP etc pour organiser
facilement des choses autant là avec
enfin c'est devenu c'est devenu trop
compliqué trop prenant pour suivre
l'expérience et donc ça s'est arrêté ça
s'est arrêté en 2011 voilà il y a plus
d'activité du tout et je n'ai pas créé
ce je n'ai pas développé ce genre
d'activité
après 2011
merci mais enfin ma dernière question
est-ce que Monsieur Thierry Mariani
était associé dans ce projet
ou dans
ce projet de du sac Talleyrand puisque
[Musique]
il est lui-même président du dialogue
franco-russe donc comment se positionner
votre projet du cercle tallean par
rapport au dialogue Franco russe auquel
appartient et Monsieur Mariani merci
alors
Thierry n'a pas il n'y a aucun il y
avait aucun lien entre
l'association Talleyrand et le dialogue
franco-rus
Thierry meriani a accepté de recevoir la
délégation des Russes au ministère de
les transports
l'entretien a duré une heure et
il y a pas plus de liens il y a pas eu
plus de contacts etc que cet entretien
d'une heure qu'il avait accordé qu'il
avait accordé à la délégation russe
j'ajoute
puisque vous avez fait tout à l'heure le
il a été mentionné
RT et Spoutnik je crois que
omerta
n'a rien à voir ni de près ni de loin
avec ces deux médias puisque le modèle
nous ne recevons pas nous ne recevons
évidemment pas d'argent de l'étranger
que ce soit d'une entité publique ou
d'une personne privée dans l'étranger je
n'ai moi même pas le passeport russe
et deuxièmement ces médias étaient
subventionnés légalement par de l'argent
étranger
nous ne recevons pas de subventions et
le comment dire
la pérennité de Merta n'est pas
uniquement des abonnements
français puisque même les Russes ne
peuvent pas s'abonner puisque les cartes
bancaires russes n'ont pas de sont
coupées du système Swift ça veut dire
que
l'intégralité des abonnés d'omerta
provient de France éventuellement un peu
de Belgique et de Suisse mais on n'est
pas du tout ni de près ni de loin dans
le cas nièreté
merci beaucoup ça n'était pas ma
question la dernière partie de votre
réponse mais elle était intéressante et
je note votre application à montrer
combien vous vous distanciez de ces
médias russes
merci Madame j'étais une question je
voudrais revenir sur la question
d'incente sur la liste des invités à
cette soirée de lancement ce que je ne
comprends pas dans votre réponse
monsieur d'Anjou c'est que si les gens
sont inscrits vous avez quand même bien
une liste et pour des raisons de
sécurité comme s'il y a des élus
notamment si vos annulations avec avec
des pressions fait par des groupes des
groupements d'intérêts je ne il y avait
bien un risque de sécurité donc vous
n'avez pas cherché à savoir
quelle personnalité
était susceptible de venir pour en
assurer la sécurité ou éviter tout
trouble à l'ordre public y compris
d'ailleurs des personnalités hostiles
alors il y avait bien un listing que je
n'ai pas avec moi mais que je pourrais
éventuellement faire ressortir ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que on avait un
listing de d'invité
qu'on connaissait et par exemple
monsieur scarzini monsieur Guéno etc des
personnalités qui étaient je dirais
invité par nos soins mais
80% des gens qui ont assisté à la soirée
se sont inscrits sur le via le site
internet en payant leur place etc alors
effectivement les noms on les a le
listing on l'a puisque les gens étaient
pointés à l'entrée après dans les la
majorité des gens qui sont inscrits on a
effectivement essayé de faire un comment
dire un filtrage un peu sommaire puisque
il y avait sur Twitter notamment des des
menaces de groupe
LGBT ou antifa de déstabiliser la soirée
des appels à perturber la soirée pour
qu'elle n'ait pas lieu etc donc on a
essayé de faire avec l'équipe un peu un
filtrage des gens qui s'inscrivaient
qu'on ne connaissait pas pour voir s'il
y avait sur Google tout simplement
Google ils ont des gens pour voir s'il y
avait une appartement
un mouvement extrémiste extrême gauche
qui nous était hostile qui avait appelé
à qui avait appelé à nous déstabiliser
honnêtement ça a pas donné grand chose
et
[Musique]
ma question en tant que président de
commission je dois d'obtenir des
réponses des commissaires et ma question
c'était pas de savoir si vous aviez
bloqué des des personnes l'utilisais
l'exemple des groupements d'intérêts au
style pour savoir si vous avez une liste
donc il y a une liste donc je ne
comprends pas pourquoi vous n'avez pas
été capable de répondre à la question
madame gente pour savoir qui était
présent et vous avez dit aussi qu'il y
avait des gens qui avaient été vidé par
nos par vos soins donc je me permets de
reposer entre président de la commission
la question madame gente est-ce que vous
avez invité par vos soins des
personnalités du rassemblement national
si oui quels sont telles et questions
madame gente aussi
si vous avez un listing j'imagine que
s'il y a des personnalités du
rassemblement national ou d'autres
parties vous avez cité les républicains
dans votre première réponse
c'est bien que enfin on les connaît
quand même enfin c'est pas des militants
anonymes enfin je pense pour connaître
un peu madame la vice-présidente que sa
question portait sur des personnalités
politiques qu'on est responsabilités
dans le débat public pas un responsable
de canton ou un militant aussi
respectable qu'un autre mais qui n'a pas
de de de responsabilité politique je
rappelle que notre commission d'enquête
se penche sur les ingérences
susceptibles d'avoir de l'influence sur
le débat politique
alors il y avait un peu plus de 600
personnes à la soirée donc là j'ai
malheureusement pas pu préparer la
question donc je pourrais éventuellement
ressortir le listing et vous apporter
une réponse plus précise ultérieurement
la grande majorité était des inconnus
sont responsabilités comme vous venez de
soigner national dans le débat public
etc c'était des gens qui s'intéressaient
au projet ça c'est la masse et sur la
masse sur 600 personnes je connaissais
peut-être 50 personnes maximum alors sur
les responsables de toute façon c'est
pas tellement
secret puisque il y a eu des articles du
Monde de la lettre A et de Mediapart sur
le sujet la commission d'enquête
parlementaire la commission d'enquête
parlementaire vous additionne sous
serment et vous demande s'il y avait des
personnalités politiques appartenant à
son national ou républicains que vous
connaissez qui sont identifiables et
identifiés facilement avec cette soirée
de lancement point final donc au début
on a l'impression qu'il y avait rien en
travaillant un peu dans son compte il y
a quand même une liste et on découvre
aussi vous l'avez dit dans votre
deuxième réponse que vous n'avez pas dit
à la première qui avait des gens que
vous avez invité par vos soins donc je
répète ma question pour la deuxième fois
et troisième fois si on prend en compte
dans la Mégane t euh par vos soins
avez-vous invité des personnalités
durant son national ou des républicains
vous avez été monsieur Guénon je pense
qu'il est pas qu'il n'est plus adhérent
républicain et
dans la listing dans le livre que vous
avez consulté dans les 50 noms que vous
venez de citer qui vous disent quelque
chose est-ce que il y avait des
personnalités une fois plus duraration
nationale ou des républicains ou
d'autres pas d'ailleurs d'autres
personnalités identifiables susceptibles
d'intéresser la Commission dans le cadre
de nos travaux que vous connaissez
alors je peux je vous dis je n'ai pas le
listing sous les yeux je peux pas vous
répondre dans le détail précisément il y
avait des personnalités du rassemblement
national oui il y avait des
personnalités des républicains oui il y
avait des journalistes oui d'autres
médias de gens qui d'ailleurs de médias
qui n'ont pas couvert le la soirée de
lancement
des personnalités de premier plan je ne
crois pas je ne crois pas
moi j'ai personnellement invité très peu
de après peut-être que Régis invité des
personnes mais chacun invité un peu
aussi son entourage et les gens qui le
souhaitaient
moi j'ai invité quelques personnes pour
répondre
des personnalités de premier plan je ne
crois pas voilà après
c'est pas un secret la soirée était
ouverte à la presse si vous voulez avoir
des réponses plus précises il va falloir
que je comment dire que je puisse
consulter le listing des invités et que
je puisse vous répondre précisément
sur ce point là ça je vous avoue que
échappe un peu j'étais moi-même très
pris pendant la soirée j'ai pas pu
parler avec beaucoup de personnes donc
personnalité de premier plan je ne crois
pas voilà je vous remercie bien écoutez
je vais vous dire par dessus le Sony la
commission vous demande effectivement
pour afin que la réponse qui est une
réponse soit portée à cette question de
consulter le listing et de nous
l'envoyer alors dans le cadre du respect
de la rgpd évidemment mais de nous
envoyer une réponse
circonstanciée que le transmettrai
évidemment à l'ensemble des commissaires
monsieur le sommier avec plaisir non moi
je voulais juste avant à mon niveau j'ai
été également très pris par la soirée à
ma connaissance il n'y avait pas de
personnalité de premier plan du
rassemblement national dans cette dans
cette soirée voilà
je vous remercie ma question je l'ai
désolée c'est encore pour Monsieur
d'Anjou
moi ce que j'aimerais comprendre c'est
d'Anjou c'est comment vous vous faites
naître votre relation votre implication
enfin je sais pas comment la qualifier
en Russie à partir d'un voyage d'un
échange avec d'un échange universitaire
dans le cadre de que vous a permis de
réaliser Paris 2 s'il est bien compris
et donc vous êtes allés là-bas ça peut
court pour comprendre à comment vous
avez pu me nouer des contacts
privilégiés
qui ont l'air assez rapide puisque vous
vous fondez ce cercle assez rapidement
qui réalise d'un côté au moins des
échanges intéressants du côté français
donc vous amenez des comme des
personnalités vous a rencontré là-bas du
côté français même si vous dites que
après du côté russe c'était moins
intéressant vous avez quand même été mis
en contact avec des personnalités après
vous faites comme une carrière qui a
l'air florissante ironie puisque vous
arrivez à réunir des sommes d'argent
conséquente il y a pouvoir réinvestir
cette cette somme dans un projet qui
vous semble qui vous semble bon donc je
ne comprends pas trop en fait le comment
vous vous êtes comment vous avez obtenu
une aussi bonne connaissance
de la Russie en tout cas de des réseaux
russes que vous connaissez moi j'ai
proposé comme personnel je l'ai fait un
échange à peu près de la même durée au
Japon bon j'ai rencontré quelques
personnes mais je serais bien en peine
de d'organiser un programme ou de faire
rencontrer des personnalités du monde de
l'économie ou de l'administration
à la à comment dire à des Français ou à
des Japonais voilà donc peut-être pas
très efficace mais en tout cas en
essayant de me remettre dans dans ma
peau d'il y a d'étudiants il y a
quelques années si ça me semble un peu
léger voilà donc est-ce que vous
confirmez que c'est le seul ce voyage et
le l'événement initial et escapermie la
suite ou à ce que j'ai mal compris ce
que vous vouliez dire où est-ce qu'il y
a des éléments autres que ce voyage
universitaire qui vous a permis de faire
naître cette
cette connaissance de la Russie
alors le voyage le cercle tolérant
l'échange n'a rien à voir avec mes
affaires en Russie ou ailleurs rien du
tout il se trouve que à l'époque j'étais
intéressé par la politique et que
ayant fait moi-même un voyage d'un mois
aux États-Unis
agir et commençons à connaître un peu le
monde russe à germer l'idée d'organiser
un programme d'échanges
il se trouve que j'ai été j'ai écrit
à différents responsables politiques
notamment de l'UMP pour demander si ça
les intéressait
de recevoir
des jeunes actifs ou des étudiants en
fin de parcours russe pour leur
expliquer comment fonctionne le système
politique français etc etc et leur
permettre à ces jeunes Russes d'avoir un
échange à l'époque les relations entre
la France et la Russie sont florissante
c'est la président Sarkozy le
gouvernement Fillon tout est au beau
fixe et le je reçois un écho favorable
sans cet éco favorable j'aurais
certainement pas persévéré
donc avec peu de moyens puisqu'en fait
les participants financés que ce soit
côté français côté russe financé
eux-mêmes leurs voyages je réussis tout
simplement à monter une sur une dizaine
de jours un agenda de
d'entretien de rencontres de visites
ça se passe bien
[Musique]
on fait l'expérience une fois une fois
de chaque côté et comme je vous l'ai dit
le
[Musique]
n'étant pas une activité professionnelle
et
scénario pardonnez
à la commission d'enquête mais on les a
bien notés ma question portée sur votre
connaissance personnelle de la Russie de
sa culture sa civilisation visiblement
aussi d'un certain nombre de
personnalités qui vous a permis les
citer le cercle en loup comme un exemple
mais pas comme un relation à cause de
mon professionnel à la fois de d'avoir
cette idée et de le réaliser et ensuite
d'avoir une carrière visiblement en
Russie donc moi ma question c'est de
comprendre comment quand on est un jeune
français puis moins jeune on peut
s'expatrier dans un pays qui est quand
même extrêmement différent dont la
langue est très différente dont le le
régime
institutionnel et on peut extrêmement
différent ou la façon de faire des
affaires n'a rien à voir avec la façon
des affaires en France et que c'est en
tout cas passer le prendre à faire en
France donc moi j'essaie de comprendre
comment
vous êtes passé d'un monde à l'autre si
vous voulez aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit
vous-même vous êtes expatrié à Dubaï
donc j'aimerais comprendre comment on
arrive à ça c'est tout
alors je pense que c'est une question de
caractère j'ai jamais été fait pour être
pour le salariat j'ai toujours aimé
entreprendre et monter des projets
certains ont marché certains n'ont pas
marché j'ai toujours pris des risques
ma connaissance de la Russie et bien
elle vient du fait que j'ai vécu
plusieurs années
et que même en habitant en France
j'ai toujours continué à travailler en
Russie au rythme d'un ou deux voire plus
à les retours par mois qui avait pas que
la Russie aussi étant en France je
voyageais au Kazakhstan en Ukraine en
Roumanie dans d'autres pays donc j'ai
toujours c'est une application qui est
comment dire
qui n'est pas récente et quand vous
travaillez ce que l'essentiel de mes
clients était français sur des
problématiques compliquées et bien vous
êtes amené à vous faire un réseau sur
place à développer comment dire
au sein de la Communauté française et
aussi au sein comment dire des des
élites économiques
politiques vous rencontrez des gens etc
et puis après charge à vous de le faire
fructifier à un moment ou un autre de
mettre des gens en relation d'activer
des relais etc voilà donc ça je dirais
c'est
ça demande de vivre à l'étranger et dans
le pays en question ce que j'ai fait et
c'est pas récent et deuxièmement ça
demande d'avoir une envie et l'énergie
et d'accepter la prise de risque de
monter des projets ce que j'ai toujours
fait ce que je continuerai à faire
omerthane dans les qu'un exemple je
ferai d'autres choses à première tâche
genre une vie j'ai une vie
professionnelle avant mère tâche on
aurait une après omerta et voilà
je vous remercie
j'aurai moins une dernière question pour
vous monsieur le sommet dans le cadre
avec l'expérience qu'elle a vôtre dans
dans le riche et je dis ça va plus
aucune de ironie
comment en fait
avez-vous l'impression pardon depuis que
vous avez changé de cadre de travail
que vous disposez d'une liberté
éditoriale
normale celle que vous avez connu dans
dans d'autres dans d'autres médias voilà
ce que les méthodes que vous arrivez à
mettre en place des méthodes de travail
qui sont propres à l'éthique
journalistique que vous avez mentionné à
plusieurs reprises et je l'ai noté c'est
pour ça que je me permets de vous
relancer dessus pour que ce soit bien
bien établi et question différente mais
je ne veux pas l'éviter parce qu'il
avait mentionné je ne vois pas que vous
ayez l'impression qu'il y a des bonnes
et mauvaises questions parce que c'est
pas du tout la façon dont on travaille
avec l'ensemble des commissaires dans le
respect du cas de cette commission et
sans mettre en cause des personnes
draguer des comptes vous à plusieurs
fois mentionner le fait qu'il y avait
des approximations concernant les
articles que vous avez lu les attaques
que vous avez subies ma question avec
aussi votre connaissance du milieu
médiatique est-ce que vous vous estimez
que vous êtes la cible de quelque chose
ou que le le
la question des ingérences en France
est-elle traitée de manière
journalistique selon les tigres
journalistiques que vous avez vous-même
établi
merci monsieur le Président
pour répondre à la première partie oui
j'ai vécu donc j'ai passé plus de la
moitié de ma vie à Paris Match j'ai
exercé des fonctions de grands reporters
de chefs du bureau aux États-Unis basé à
New York pendant 6 ans et pendant 11 ans
de director adjoint de la rédaction donc
des des
fonctions en tout cas pour les dernières
10 dernières années qui étaient
directement au contact enfin je gérais
une rédaction de 200 à l'époque une
centaine de reporters donc le cadre
évidemment et la notoriété de Paris
Match c'est son rapport aussi avec la
France puisque c'est pour moi plus
qu'une institut plus qu'un journal c'est
une institution véritablement
et bien évidemment ce n'est pas je n'ai
pas la même la même liberté que dont je
dispose aujourd'hui mais
moins par image c'est intéressant
absolument tous les sujets m'a donné le
loisir justement de partir en tout cas
de faire des reportages ou d'en susciter
ou d'envoyer des reporters
puisque j'étais versé pour
l'international en réalité pour être
tout à fait franc c'était peut-être plus
facile de traiter l'international à
Paris Match que le National je vais pas
revenir sur toutes les la question des
couvertures et la question de tout ce
que peut susciter ce titre dans la
société française mais sur ma partie à
moi et en tout cas qui concernait
d'abord les États-Unis pour une grosse
part et puis ensuite le reste du monde
et les conflits en particulier j'avais à
gérer voilà des des il y avait aussi le
poids d'une rédaction quand même assez
constituée et aujourd'hui je dois je
dois avouer que je suis
à Paris Match c'est toujours est-il le
petit jeune là je suis le plus ancien
donc je travaille avec des jeunes c'est
d'ailleurs un vrai découverte pour moi
qui ont pour le ou la moitié de mon âge
et qui maîtrise les outils
technologiques comme si c'était comme
ils sont nés avec d'ailleurs moi je n'ai
pas cette maîtrise je suis assez
admiratif de ceux qui sont capables de
faire notamment dans la réalisation des
documentaires et dans la mise en scène
de certains de certains de nos contenus
sur tous les réseaux sociaux etc voilà
donc oui j'ai peut-être plus de liberté
aujourd'hui
et en tout cas j'ai aussi la liberté
d'enseigner ou en tout cas de
transmettre ces valeurs du journaliste
qui pour moi me semble essentiel et que
je défendrai becquet ongles
voilà alors après sur la question du
traitement médiatique qui a été réservé
omerta vous avouerez quand même que
d'être traité de médias prorus et
d'extrême droite avant même la sortie du
magazine il y a quand même peut-être un
petit attaque quand même ou personnel
enfin je ne connais pas encore une fois
les personnes de libération qui ont
écrit cet article je les avais jamais
rencontré
j'ai découvert qu'ils avaient enquêté
sur moi qu'ils avaient appelé des gens
autour de moi ce qui est tout à fait
normal mais
j'ai accepté d'en rencontrer un donc
voilà et je me suis rendu compte que la
plupart de mes citations avaient été
tronquées dans l'article et qu'en fait
on avait fait voilà une un papier à
charge
pour régler des comptes qui me semblent
en tout cas qui ne sont pas de mon
ressort
je crois qu'il y avait en filigrane une
histoire de Bolloré aussi toujours qui
revient de façon obsessionnelle chez
certains en particulier chez libération
donc voilà on je ne je ne m'étendrai pas
là dessus j'ai remarqué qu'il y avait
une accumulation
d'attaque par un petit nombre de
journalistes sur le précise encore
on parlait de l'écho qui a eu ou en tout
cas de du retentissement certes
certaines personnes ont pu analyser
commenter ses papiers mais pour éviter
ça représente des médias qui aujourd'hui
ont une audience qui n'est plus celle
qu'ils ont eu à une époque et qui
finalement c'est un petit un petit
milieu voilà qui a décidé de nous
attaquer qui a décidé de vouloir
finalement notre morceau social quelque
part puisque vu la nature des attaques
et puis
Charles d'Anjou la précisé
ce sera évidemment ça se passera dans
les tribunaux parce que il y a des
propos ouvertement diffamatoires et qui
en tout cas me concernant et concernant
aussi Charles d'Anjou on va maintenant
cause notre notre éthique mettant cause
qui nous sommes mettre en cause nos
valeurs tout simplement quand j'ai réagi
de façon un peu violente sur cette
histoire d'agents russe je m'en excuse
peut-être que je ne visais pas du tout à
mettre en cause
la
commission mais simplement j'estime
qu'un propos comme ça lançait en plus
encore une fois par une personne que je
ne connais pas
avec qui je n'ai aucun contentieux je
trouvais ça quand même voilà c'est un
propos clairement diffamatoire et qui
vise à atteindre voilà donc je regrette
que
ces gens et peut-être une voix qu'on
entend plus qu'on devrait l'entendre
voilà mais en tout cas la plupart des
autres médias n'ont pas traité omerta de
cette façon
merci Madame la rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président oui moi je
voudrais revenir sur l'une des questions
que j'ai posé tout à l'heure et sur un
sujet déjà abordé mais sur lequel j'ai
pas obtenu toutes les précisions que je
souhaitais la première parce que c'était
une question que j'avais adressée
directement à Monsieur Charles d'Anjou
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est plutôt
monsieur le sommier qui a répondu parce
que je vous
demandez monsieur d'Anjou comme vous
avez été invité le premier décembre
dernier
d'une émission sur la chaîne de
télévision du ministère de la Défense
russe faites ça TV zetza
pourri par les notamment
du documentaire front russe je vais vous
demandais d'une part si vous confirmez
avoir été effectivement invité par cette
télévision du ministère de la Défense
russe et d'autre part
comment vous expliquer ce traitement
particulier pour un entrepreneur
français
de ces sommes toutes il me semble assez
inhabituel à moins que vous ne me disiez
que c'est très courant que des hommes
d'affaires français soient invités sur
la chaîne de télévision du ministère de
la Défense russe mais moi il me semble
que c'est assez
inhabituel comme traitement comme
comment expliquer vous ça je ne parle
pas cette fois-ci puisque j'ai bien
compris que Monsieur le sommier est
monté tout de suite sur ses grands
chevaux quand on parlait du documentaire
mais juste comment vous expliquer
monsieur d'Anjou
le traitement que je continue à ce stade
à considérer comme particulier
consistant à être l'invité d'une chaîne
de télévision du ministère la Défense
russe après la parution d'un
documentaire
oui bah j'ai reçu cette invitation c'est
pas moi qui est sollicité qui a demandé
d'être invité j'ai reçu cette invitation
et j'ai accepté puisque le documentaire
venait de sortir
il se trouve que le documentaire vous
pourrez le je pense qu'il faut voir le
documentaire absolument pour répondre
totalement à la question vous faire une
idée complète le documentaire n'est
absolument pas pour russe il montre le
quotidien de la vie sur
dans les territoires pris par les Russes
de manière factuelle
sans parti pris donc
je crois que
les Russes ont eux aussi leur manière de
faire
leur propagande et de faire passer leurs
idées etc par contre
je pense que ce qu'ils ont apprécié dans
le dans le documentaire c'est que
c'était un documentaire factuel qui
montrait la réalité sur le front
d'ailleurs Régis a dit dans le
documentaire on voit
Régis comment dire avec les enseignants
à kirson
qui évacue la question de l'eau de mort
on voit Régis poser à plusieurs reprises
la question de logo mort a déjà été
apportée à la commission voilà donc ce
que je voulais dire c'est que c'est
absolument pas un documentaire
complaisant simplement la question
une fois plus je suis obligé de
d'intervenir ce qui ne m'arrive pourtant
peu depuis 5 mois
la question de la rapporteur n'était pas
sur la qualité du reportage qu'elle n'a
jamais mentionné y compris lors de sa
première question
c'était sur le fait que vous ayez choisi
d'aller d'honorer je pense que c'est le
bon mot une invitation de l'arme et de
la chaîne que sais pas moi mais TVA qui
donc une chaîne de l'armée russe ou en
tout cas liée à l'armée russe donc la
question que vous a posé mes rapporteur
c'est pourquoi avez-vous choisi d'y
aller vous dites la réponse c'est parce
que comme le documentaire va être sortir
excusez-moi entreprise de la commission
d'enquête le considère que c'est une
réponse non satisfaisante
pour Pascal documentaire vient de sortir
qu'on accepte une invitation de l'armée
russe qui est en guerre de manière j'ai
pas fini je n'ai pas fini mon
intervention qui est en guerre contre de
manière illégale et condamnée par un
pays dont vous êtes ressortissant et
dont vous êtes patriotes revendiqué vous
allez
armée russe qui par ailleurs on peut en
discuter pour ça suffisamment informé à
des implications directes ou indirectes
dans des attaques contre notre pays en
tout cas les attaques virtuelles et
aussi un comportement à travers Wagner
en Afrique qui ne meurt pas moins qu'on
puisse dire le sort de nos sentiments
nationaux et nos intérêts nationaux donc
ce que je ne comprends pas et je repose
la question la Commission voudrait
savoir pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
choisi
d'honorer l'invitation de cette chaîne
et sans mentionner la qualité que nous
n'avons parce que moi je n'ai pas vu du
documentaire
mais vous savez par principe je ne
refuse pas les invitations donc je suis
invité sur une chaîne russe pour parler
du documentaire pas pour parler d'une
position sur la guerre en Ukraine pour
parler du documentaire dont ils ont
choisi de diffuser un extrait sans tout
à fait normal d'accepter l'invitation
pas d'y aller toutes les semaines
pas d'être chroniqueur payé par la
chaîne d'y aller pour commenter le
documentaire ça me paraît tout à fait
normal et d'ailleurs je vais vous dire
il se trouve que je suis comme ils ont
boudoul comme un certain comme Christian
Estrosi sur une liste noire en Ukraine
de personnalités qui sont interdites et
qui sont d'ailleurs plus qu'interdites
qui n'ont auquel on fait pour certaines
la chasse c'est à dire que mon adresse
personnelle en Russie a été diffusée sur
cette sur ce sur ce site internet
c'est dommage parce que j'aurais bien
aimé pouvoir faire aussi pourquoi pas
des reportages côté Ukrainiens
simplement
et bien parfois vous êtes invité parfois
vous êtes personne à notre gratin moi
j'ai pas de j'ai travaillé en Ukraine
j'ai des amis Ukrainiens j'ai pas de
problème à y travailler allez faire
éventuellement soutenir des reportages
sur pas etc voilà par principe je ne
refuse pas les invitations quand elles
ont un quand elles ont du sens là
c'était sur le documentaire ça avait du
son je me suis rendu et voilà
je note simplement et nous allons tout
s'en prendre acte et compris celles et
ceux qui auront l'amabilité de
s'intéresser à nos travaux que vous avez
trouvé tout à fait normal
quelques mois après l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par l'Amérique de vous rendre
parce que l'invitation vous été faite
sur une chaîne de télévision
proche de l'armée russe bon chacun
jugera je pense qu'on va pas épiloguer
là-dessus mais vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir vous connaissez bien la Russie
manifestement vous en parlez longue vous
y avez vécu longtemps et vous avez
manifestement toujours des liens que il
aurait été difficile
d'imaginer aller sur une chaîne de
télévision de l'armée russe proche du
ministère de la Défense russe pour y
avoir un discours un temps soit peu non
pas critique mais je dirais un peu
objectif et factuel sur sur l'invasion
par la plus de de l'Ukraine mais voilà
donc nous nous prenons acte je souhaite
également revenir sur un sujet sur
lequel
je voudrais être sûr d'avoir exactement
compris et que les membres de la
commission d'enquête ont exactement
compris ce que vous avez dit c'est ce
que j'ai qualifié d'affaires de drones
de livraison de drones envisagés annoncé
par vous en mai 22 lorsque vous êtes
invité à vous exprimer devant le cigare
club de Moscou qui est une une
organisation
qui entretient des liens assez étroits
avec le pouvoir un lieu de voilà de
convivialité assez chic on va dire et
assez bien connecté avec avec les
cercles du pouvoir la Douma etc
et donc
il y a eu manifestement des déclarations
qui vous ont été prêtés parce qu'elles
ont été relayées sur le site à plusieurs
reprises du cigare club
tendance à faire croire que vous alliez
lever des fonds pour et que vous
appeliez à lever des fonds pour opérer
une livraison de drones dans les
républiques auto proclamés de données
et puis
manifestement il y a eu des corrections
des textes publiés par le cigare club
récemment qui qui font un espèce de
rétropédalage et ne mentionne plus de
livraison de drôles ou de projets voilà
enfin bon donc vous n'ayez absolument
vous vous confirmez que vous n'ayez
absolument avoir dit quoi que ce soit
devant le cyber club Moscou vite
concernant un projet de de collecte de
fonds pour organiser des livraisons de
de drones que c'est je reprends les
termes les Russes qui sont quelquefois
un peu mal organisés vous avez dit ça
vous même qui qui aurait pu
entraîner comme conséquence que des
informations pas vérifiées pafiables
plusieurs fois écrites réécrites enlever
modifier etc aurait été publié vous vous
confirmez que vous n'avez rien dit de
tel devant le cigare club et que ce qui
a pu être écrit modifié ensuite et chape
totalement à
votre
entremise elle n'est pas du tout votre
fête
alors je vous le confirme
je vous confirme que ça fait partie
comme j'ai déjà dit de la plainte contre
le média qui a mentionné ces éléments
deuxièmement sur la participation j'y
reviens
à cette émission elle est ponctuelle et
heureusement que on peut aussi se rendre
sur des chaînes avec lesquelles on n'est
pas forcément d'accord c'est le cas en
France quand LCI et BFM reçoit
il y a plusieurs reprises vice-président
de la Douma francophone Dimitri pescoff
porte parole du Kremlin Dimitri belve
ancien président soutien inconditionnel
de à la guerre etc etc ou que TF1 ou
France 2 vont faire des reportages chez
les tchétchène avec l'armée de kadirof
dans les centres d'entraînement etc la
question de se pose pas je l'ai accepté
une invitation pour participer à une
émission sur mon documentaire je vois
absolument pas quel est le problème il y
a aucun sous-entendu il y a aucun
soutien de ma part ni à la chaîne il y a
l'armée russe etc c'était une invitation
pour parler de mon documentaire point
barre
PRIAC de votre réponse et
reprenons acte de la deuxième réponse
même rapporte que vous aviez une autre
question
madame gente
je vous remercie monsieur le sommier
un complément d'information sur une
question que vous avez posé tout à
l'heure il n'y avait aucun cadre du RN
aucun cadre des républicains à la soirée
d'inauguration d'omerta que vous avez pu
vérifier cette information d'accord très
bien je vous remercie pour pour ce
complément information utile pour le
coup à nos travaux puisque nous savons
comme ça une réponse
factuelle je vous remercie monsieur le
sommier pour cette réponse et pour votre
le temps et les réponses que vous
apportez à notre commission je remercie
Monsieur d'Anjou de cette rendu
disponible à distance et d'avoir pris le
temps de répondre à nos questions je
remercie les services de l'Assemblée
ceux qui ont permis cette connexion
sécurisée depuis
la Turquie
qui leur permet de ne pas mettre en
cause évidemment la sécurité de notre
assemblée qui a été visée je le rappelle
pour ceux qui nous regardent par une
attaque visiblement en prenant de Russie
de hacker russe lors de du de la
discussion autour de la discussion de la
résolution de la qualité pour faire
reconnaître le de mort comme un génocide
proposition qui a été votée à la quasi
uneanimité des groupes je vous remercie
une fois de plus je remercie madame la
rapporteur madame la commissariat gente
et je vous souhaite une bonne soirée et
je lève la séance merci au revoir